there is a mission up in space called
the lisa pathfinder doing some
experiments and it's a slightly strange
mission in the what it's got it's got
two little gold cubes out there and the
slightly strange thing about it is the
the point of the experiment in some
sense isn't the spacecraft around them
it's the two little gold cubes in the
middle it's the beginning of the
development of the next generation of
gravitational wave detectors so ligo has
demonstrated that we can detect
gravitational waves but gravitational
waves are waves right so they have a
wavelength associated with them or a
characteristic frequency and ligo is
able to measure waves that have got a
frequency of about
hundred hertz
if theories are correct and they're
beginning to look like they're correct
general relativity tells you that
we can produce gravitational waves over
a whole range of wavelengths and
frequencies in particular we can produce
very large wavelength events if two
galaxies merge together and we know that
happens
the centers of the two galaxies have
supermassive black holes in them and we
know that they're going to combine and
begin to go around and they'll go around
much slower than the 30 solar mass black
holes that we've seen the corresponding
gravitational waves will have a much
lower frequency or a much higher
wavelength
so in order to detect them you've
actually got to go
beyond the earth you've actually got to
go out into space and the whole idea of
the experiment is to find out whether
you really can have these sort of
free-floating little cubes
and whether you can put an entire
spacecraft around them and they still
essentially remain as free-floating
cubes so really the cubes are just
floating there and the spacecraft has to
stay in the right place to keep the you
know not to nudge the cube in any way so
the boxes are in in the lisa pathfinder
but not touching the walls of the lisa
pathfinder they're just following lisa
pathfinders on a you know on a free fall
trajectory and these boxes are as well
and of course that's actually i mean you
know physically that's not so hard to do
because actually you can have a little
cube and then because it's you know
you're out there in space so it's
actually just gonna hang there and you
can put a spacecraft around it but of
course as soon as the cube starts to
charge up a little bit if there's any
electric charge on the
satellite around it that's going to
start pulling it one way or the other if
there are magnetic fields in there
that's going to start pulling it around
so the question is whether you can
really effectively put this whole space
probe around the cube and it not
disturbed the cube in any way lisa
pathfinder went up was launched in
december it's about one and a half
million kilometers from earth between
the earth and the sun where the
gravitational potential the pull of the
sun on the on the lisa pathfinder it
exactly balances the pull of the earth
and the gravitational so the two little
cubes in there about 40 centimeters
apart and so actually they're doing
experiments to see whether they can sort
of figure out the distance between them
and maintain the station between them at
that distance they're trying to see how
well they can measure the differences so
that they can understand what's causing
the differences a they've got to be able
to understand what forces are acting on
these bodies
there's there's solar wind there's
various pressures from things like the
solar wind and particles and so they
they're following the trajectory of
these objects and they've discovered
that the sensitivity that their
experiment can reach is already i think
at least five times better than they
think they will need
for the actual mission so this is sort
of technology proving they're really
just trying to figure out what the
limits are of what you can do
and the big goal here is they want to
scale the whole thing up that basically
at the moment these two cubes are about
40 centimeters apart they want to do an
experiment where the two
little gold cubes are actually a million
kilometers apart and if you put the two
cubes a million kilometers apart there's
some really quite exciting science you
can start doing the complete mission
will actually have three spacecraft this
is a thing called e-lisa which i think
stands for the evolved laser
interferometers space antennae or
something like that anyway but it's
basically an experiment to detect
gravitational waves and they're going to
have three of these spacecraft out there
one's going to have two cubes in it and
then you have two other ones which have
one cube in each in the in the final
experiment what you've got is you've got
this constellation of three
satellites that are kind of following
the earth around so the earth's in orbit
around the sun you've got this
constellation of three satellites
they're all in separate orbits around
the sun
going
more or less tracking the earth's orbit
but they're on slightly inclined orbits
and so the net effect of that is as they
track around they kind of rotate around
and so you've got the earth going around
the sun these satellites following us
along and kind of this rotating
constellation of three satellites and
essentially
there are kind of two pairs of cubes in
that way so you've got the kind of two
arms of this uh this gravitational wave
telescope the other really important
thing is can you
measure exactly where the cube is within
the spacecraft
so part of the experiment is actually to
determine the position of the cube
within the spacecraft and that's partly
just to make sure the spacecraft stays
in the right place but it's also because
of the way this experiment works the way
the experiment the full size experiment
works is you need to measure the
distance between these two little cubes
because when one of these gravitational
waves goes past space shrinks and
expands a little bit and so the distance
between them shifts a little bit the way
you measure the distance between these
cubes is you actually measure the
distance between the two spacecraft and
then you measure the distance between
the spacecraft and the cube or where
within the spacecraft the cube is at
each end and by combining those three
bits of information that basically tells
you how too far apart the two cubes
actually are and so part of what they're
doing with just this one spacecraft is
figuring out quite how accurately they
can measure where within the spacecraft
the cube is exactly to within you know a
tiny fraction of the size of an atom so
you want something which is fairly
non-reactive so it's not out gassing so
it's not kind of jet propelling itself
around and doing anything else that
might move it around you want something
which is reflective because actually
you're bouncing laser beams off these
things in order to to measure exactly
where they are because they're using
these techniques called interferometry
which involves bouncing a laser beam
backwards and forwards to actually
figure out exactly where the cube is um
so you just want something which is sort
of very passive but also reflects light
so as one of these waves goes past they
really are just literally expansions and
contractions of space so so these cubes
will as space expands and contracts
between them get a little further apart
and a little closer together and
depending on what the astrophysical
sources which is producing the
gravitational waves
as we've seen with the ligo experiment
you will get these very characteristic
signatures and you can actually use that
to infer a lot about what it is that's
produced the gravitational wave in the
first place
you seem to get so excited about
spaceships and spacecraft do you ever
think you chose the wrong job
if you give me an engineering job and a
spaceship then that thing wouldn't fly
they'll merge into a bigger black hole
right and so they merge into this bigger
black hole which actually is estimated
to be about i think 62 solar mass black
hole
and
this the remnant energy there's still
energy left